en salle ou en terrasse les
restaurateurs peuvent à présent reposer
cette fameuse question
suite aux annonces des manuels macron
même si le temps n'est pas encore au
beau fixe
la réouverture des salles divise la
clientèle sera que c'est quand même plus
agréable de s'asseoir de se poser de
manger sur place
c'est une bête dehors je pense c'est à
dire libre partie nous manquait les
gestes barrières sont respectés la
distance et respectez donc ça va il ya
pas de en terrasse ou intérieure se
passe pas un problème
surpris par les annonces du président ce
restaurateur de montigny le bretonneux a
eu à peine le temps de se préparer pour
la réouverture
il a rappelé dimanche soir c'est aux
salariés pour revenir travailler à temps
plein ce lundi matin
pour nous c'est un soulagement de
pouvoir ouvrir
on attendait depuis tellement longtemps
de retrouver un peu une vie normale
néanmoins quand même de d'ouvrir en
prévenant on peut s'arrêter n'aura pu
s'organiser mieux nous on travaille
essentiellement quasiment que des
produits frais donc pour
s'approvisionner c'est pas évident une
table sur deux est occupé par des
clients et sur ses deux salles une seule
est ouverte ce qui représente 40
couverts sur 80 depuis le 2 juin il a dû
investir pour pouvoir accueillir plus de
monde en terrasse va terrasse derrière
je peux mettre beaucoup de monde mais
comme nos clients ne savaient pas et que
la copropriété a nous a alloué sept
espaces et que le temps de d'acheter le
matériel parce que encore une fois quand
vous allez faire des achats pour une
terrasse vous n'avez pas forcément tout
l'équipement forcément notre activité
est très impacté
en tout cas on espère des si la fin
d'année retrouvez un écran
fonctionnement plutôt normal pour
rouvrir totalement les restaurateurs
devront respecter un protocole strict 10
clients maximum par table
rendre le port du masque obligatoire
pour se déplacer dans le restaurant et
espacer les tables d'un mètre